what some see is a u-turn on closing the
border with Mexico Donald Trump sees
differently I'm a shut it down at some
point but I'd rather do tariffs so
Mexico I have to say has been very very
good with that praise for Mexico for he
says stemming the flow of migrants he
headed for the border even allies had
warned him closing it would bring
economic catastrophe angus emergency at
the border is fake but he thinks it's a
vote winner the campaign for his
reelection released this ad going after
the democrats who want to replace him
for their approach to immigration and
for the president's arrival in
california a state that sworn to defy
his agenda who's exactly the sort of
welcome you'd expect people feel very
strongly against his attitude officials
listen to trump had come to see what he
claims is the first section of his much
promised wall but is in fact the long
planned replacement of a fence that was
already there at a meeting with those
who police the border he was presented
with a piece of the wall and outlined
what he says is a crisis of migrants
trying to enter the country illegally
it's a colossal surge and it's
overwhelming our immigration system and
we can't let that happen so as i say and
this is our new statement the system is
full can't take you anymore
whether it's asylum whether it's
anything you want it's illegal
immigration can't take you anymore we
can't take you our country is full and
there are those who support him so the
border wall were
for us for Border Patrol agents a border
wall system is what works we need the
border barrier we need to provide the
requirements that meet our need in this
case for us it's 30 feet high but
Trump's opponents accuse him of
manufacturing this crisis and his visit
came as California and 19 other states
filed a lawsuit to prevent him from
diverting money from other projects to
pay for the wall he's made those 2,000
miles of America's border with Mexico
defining to his presidency an issue that
was divisive in the election Trump won
remains divisive now and is certain to
be just as polarizing when America
decides if Donald Trump will get a
second term in office Gregg Milam Sky
News Los Angeles